[تصفيق]
لا متزايد في مجلس النواب الامريكي لتبني
نهج امريكي جديد للتعامل مع ايران في ضوء
استمرار انتهاكات النظام ضد الشعب
الايراني اكثر من 220 نائبا من الحزبين
ايدوا قرارا يدعم الشعب الايراني ويعترفوا
بحقه باقامه نظام ديمقراطيه ويدين مواصفه
بالقتل الوحشي للمتظاهرين
سوف يسمع الرئيس صوت الكونغرس وامنوا ان
يقف معنا غالبا ما يريد التفاوض مع حكومه
ايران وهذا خطا بالنسبه لي لانهم لا
يتفاوضون بحسن نيه لذلك امل ان يسمع صوتنا
باننا نعارض النظام الذي يريد ديمقراطيه
وحريه وايران غير نوويه تعيش في سلام مع
جيرانها
القرار يدين ايضا ووصفها بالهجمات
الارهابيه التي يرعاها النظام الايراني ضد
مواطني الولايات المتحده ومسؤوليها وكذلك
المعارضين الايرانيين
هذا القرار مهم لانه في اول 50 يوما من
الكونجرس الجديد لقد عمل من غالبيه
225 عضوا في الكونجرس ديمقراطيون
وجمهوريون من اجل ايران حره ومن اجل
جمهوريه ايران
نجحت المعارضه الايرانيه من حشد تاييد
كبير لهذا القرار من خلال ناخبها
الامريكيين من اصل الايرانيه في مختلف
الولايات وهو ما بدا واضحا من دعم الحزبين
له في مجلس النواب
الدور القيادي للنساء الايرانيات في
الانتفاضه الحاليه لقى ايضا تاييدا خاصه
في ظل تطور قضيه الهجمات السامه على مدارس
الفتيات والتي تتهم الحكومه الايرانيه
بالوقوف خلفها
من المحزن ان نسمع عن التسمم وهو غريب
للغايه ولكن للاسف هذا نتيجه نظام
استبدادي وسيكون من الصعب تحديد المسؤول
عما حدث في ظل نظام يعيش بحكم السلاح لكن
خلاصه القول هي ان النساء يتعرضن للهجوم
وطريقه الحل هي العمل على الترويج لنظام
الديمقراطي
وفي سياق المسار الجديد يدعو القرار
الحكومه الامريكيه للعمل مع حلفائها
الاوروبيين لمحاسبه طهران على انتهاك
الامتيازات الدبلوماسيه ودعوه الدولي الى
منع الانشطه الخبيثه للبعثات الدبلوماسيه
الايرانيه بهدف اغلاقها وترضي وكلائها
حسين الطوط العربيه واشنطن